أتساءل عما إذا كان بإمكانك تزويدنا جميعًا
ببعض المعلومات المستجدة عن
مكان وجود قائد فاجنر الذي
تحصل عليه مسبقًا ، هل هو في
بيلاروسيا أم لا
فيما يتعلق بالتطهير الذي هو في
سانت بطرسبرغ
أو ربما يسافر هذا الصباح إلى
موسكو أو في أي مكان آخر
لكنها ليست موجودة في أراضي
بيلاروسيا الآن ،
لذا فهو ليس في بيلاروسيا وهذا
المسار يتعارض مع التصريحات التي
أدلى بها الزعيم الروسي بيلا في
الماضي بأنه كان في بيلاروسيا
ويطرح السؤال برمته هل
هذه الصفقة  التي تم التفاوض عليها لإنهاء
انتفاضة فاجنر الأسبوع الماضي ، هل يتم
إعادة التفاوض عليها لأن التلفزيون الحكومي في
روسيا في وقت سابق اليوم يبث
صورًا لما يقولون إنها مداهمة للشرطة
أعطيها لمنزل بريجوسي في سانت
بطرسبرغ ، على الأقل ،
استولى أحدهم على الذهب  يحجب جوازات
السفر النقدية بأسماء مزيفة عليها على
ما يبدو أنها تنتمي إلى evgeny Prague
والشعر المستعار الذي يُفترض أنه يستخدم للتخفي ، إنها
عملية كاملة نوع من القمع
يبدو أنه يتعلق بأي شيء مع Wagner
أي شيء له علاقة بالتقدم المتطور
ولا يبشر بالخير بالنسبة  الرجل الذي
ترأس فاجنر بالطبع لا يزال يترأسه
ولكن من قاد ذلك التمرد ضد
الكرملين ولذا سنرى ما سيحدث في
المستقبل لوكاشينكو زعيم
بيلاروسيا يقول إنه لا يعرف ما
سيحدث لكنه قال إنه
لم يفعل  لا أعتقد أن بوتين سيقتل
بريوجين ، فقد قال إن هذا ليس شيئًا
يعتقد أنه سيحدث ، لكن
حقيقة أنه أثار إمكانية
قتل التقدم لا تبشر
بالخير لزعيم فاجنر